[MUSIC PLAYING BY J.S. BACH]
PROFESSOR: The last time we
began having a look at how
languages are constructed.
Remember the main point that an
evaluator for, LISP, say,
has two main elements.
There is EVAL, and EVAL's job
is to take in an expression
and an environment and turn that
into a procedure and some
arguments and pass that
off to APPLY.
And APPLY takes the procedure
in the arguments, turns that
back into, in a general case,
another expression to be
evaluated in another environment
and passes that
off to EVAL, which passes it
to APPLY, and there's this
whole big circle where things
go around and around and
around until you get either to
some very primitive data or to
a primitive procedure.
See, what this cycle has to do
with is unwinding the means of
combination and the means of
abstraction in the language.
So for instance, you have
a procedure in LISP-- a
procedure is a general way of
saying, I want to be able to
evaluate this expression for
any value of the arguments,
and that's sort of what's
going on here.
That's what APPLY does.
It says the general thing coming
in with the arguments
reduces to the expression that's
the body, and then if
that's a compound expression
or another procedure
application, the thing will go
around and around the circle.
Anyway, that's sort of the basic
structure of gee, pretty
much any interpreter.
The other thing that you saw
is once you have the
interpreter in your hands, you
have all this power to start
playing with the language.
So you can make it dynamically
scoped, or you can put in
normal order evaluation, or you
can add new forms to the
language, whatever you like.
Or more generally, there's this
notion of metalinguistic
abstraction, which says that
part of your perspective as an
engineer, as a software
engineer, but as an engineer
in general is that you can gain
control of complexity by
inventing new languages
sometimes.
See, one way to think about
computer programming is that
it only incidentally has
to do with getting a
computer to do something.
Primarily what a computer
program has to do with, it's a
way of expressing ideas with
communicating ideas.
And sometimes when you want to
communicate new kinds of
ideas, you'd like to invent new
modes of expressing that.
Well, today we're going to apply
this framework to build
a new language.
See, once we have the basic idea
of the interpreter, you
can pretty much go build any
language that you like.
So for example, we can go
off and build Pascal.
And gee, we would worry about
syntax and parsing and various
kinds of compiler optimizations,
and there are
people who make honest livings
doing that, but at the level
of abstraction that we're
talking, a Pascal interpreter
would not look very different at
all from what you saw Gerry
do last time.
Instead of that, we'll spend
today building a really
different language, a language
that encourages you to think
about programming not in terms
of procedures, but in a really
different way.
And the lecture today is going
to be at two levels
simultaneously.
On the one hand, I'm going to
show you what this language
looks like, and on the other
hand, I'll show you how it's
implemented.
And we'll build an
implementation in LISP and see
how that works.
And you should be drawing
lessons on two levels.
The first is to realize
just how different a
language can be.
So if you think that the jump
from Fortran to LISP is a big
deal, you haven't seen
anything yet.
And secondly, you'll see that
even with such a very
different language, which will
turn out to not have
procedures at all and not talk
about functions at all, there
will still be this basic cycle
of eval and apply that's
unwinds the means of combination
and the means an
abstraction.
And then thirdly, as kind of a
minor but elegant technical
point, you'll see a nice
use of streams to avoid
backtracking.
OK, well, I said that this
language is very different.
To explain that, let's go back
to the very first idea that we
talked about in this course, and
that was the idea of the
distinction between the
declarative knowledge of
mathematics--
the definition of a square root
as a mathematical truth--
and the idea that computer
science talks about the how to
knowledge--
contrast that definition of
square root with a program to
compute a square root.
That's where we started off.
Well, wouldn't it be great if
you could somehow bridge this
gap and make a programming
language which sort of did
things, but you talked about
it in terms of truth, in
declarative terms?
So that would be a programming
language in
which you specify facts.
You tell it what is.
You say what is true.
And then when you want an
answer, somehow the language
has built into it automatically
general kinds of
how to knowledge so it can just
take your facts and it
can evolve these methods on
its on using the facts you
gave it and maybe some general
rules of logic.
So for instance, I might go up
to this program and start
telling it some things.
So I might tell it that the
son of Adam is Abel.
And I might tell it that the
son of Adam is Cain.
son of Cain is Enoch.
And I might tell it that the son
of Enoch is Irad, and all
through the rest of our chapter
whatever of Genesis,
which ends up ending in Adah, by
the way, and this shows the
genealogy of Adah from Cain.
Anyway, once you tell
it these facts, you
might ask it things.
You might go up to your language
and say, who's the
son of Adam?
And you can very easily imagine
having a little
general purpose search program
which would be able to go
through and in response to that
say, oh yeah, there are
two answers: the son of
Adam is Abel and the
son of Adam is Cain.
Or you might say, based on the
very same facts, who is Cain
the son of?
And then you can imagine
generating another slightly
different search program which
would be able to go through
and checked for who is
Cain, and son of, and
come up with Adam.
Or you might say, what's
the relationship
between Cain and Enoch?
And again, a minor variant
on that search program.
You could figure out that
it said son of.
But even here in this very
simple example, what you see
is that a single fact, see, a
single fact like the son of
Adam is Cain can be
used to answer
different kinds of questions.
You can say, who's the son of,
or you can say who's the son
of Adam, or you can say
what's the relation
between Adam and Cain?
Those are different questions
being run by different
traditional procedures all
based on the same fact.
And that's going to be the
essence of the power of this
programming style, that one
piece of declarative knowledge
can be used as the basis for
a lot of different kinds of
how-to knowledge, as opposed
to the kinds of procedures
we're writing where you sort of
tell it what input you're
giving it and what
answer you want.
So for instance, our square
root program can perfectly
well answer the question, what's
the square root of 144?
But in principle, the
mathematical definition of
square root tells you
other things.
Like it could say, what is
17 the square root of?
And that would be have
to be answered
by a different program.
So the mathematical definition,
or in general, the
facts that you give it are
somehow unbiased as to what
the question is.
Whereas the programs we tend to
write specifically because
they are how-to knowledge
tend to be looking
for a specific answer.
So that's going to be one
characteristic of what we're
talking about.
We can go on.
We can imagine that we've
given our language
some sort of facts.
Now let's give it some
rules of inference.
We can say, for instance,
if the--
make up some syntax here--
if the son of x is y--
I'll put question marks to
indicate variables here--
if the son of x is y and the
son of y is z, then the
grandson of x is z.
So I can imagine telling my
machine that rule and then
being able to say, for
instance, who's
the grandson of Adam?
Or who is Irad the
grandson of?
Or deduce all grandson
relationships you possibly can
from this information.
We can imagine somehow the
language knowing how to do
that automatically.
Let me give you maybe a little
bit more concrete example.
Here's a procedure that merges
two sorted lists.
So x and y are two, say, lists
of numbers, lists of distinct
numbers, if you like, that
are in increasing order.
And what merge does is take
two such lists and combine
them into a list where
everything's in increasing
order, and this is a pretty easy
programs that you ought
to be able to write.
It says, if x is empty,
the answer is y.
If y is empty, the
answer is x.
Otherwise, you compare the
first two elements.
So you pick out the first thing
in x and the first thing
in y, and then depending on
which of those first elements
is less, you stick the lower
one on to the result a
recursively merging, either
chopping the first one off x
or chopping the first
one off y.
That's a standard
kind of program.
Let's look at the logic.
Let's forget about the program
and look at the logic on which
that procedure is based.
See, there's some logic which
says, gee, if the first one is
less, then we get the answer by
sticking something onto the
result of recursively merging
the rest. So let's try and be
explicit about what that
logic is that's
making the program work.
So here's one piece.
Here's the piece of the program
which recursively
chops down x if the first
thing in x is smaller.
And if you want to be very
explicit about what the logic
is there, what's really going on
is a deduction, which says,
if you know that some list, that
we'll call cdr of x, and
y merged to form z, and you know
that a is less than the
first thing in y, then you know
that if you put a onto
the cdr of x, then that result
and y merge to form a onto z.
And what that is, that's the
underlying piece of logic--
I haven't written it as a
program, I wrote it a sort of
deduction that's underneath this
particular clause that
says we can use the
recursion there.
And then similar, here's
the other clause
just to complete it.
The other clause is based on
this piece of logic, which is
almost the same and I won't go
through it, and then there's
the n cases where we tested for
null, and that's based on
the idea that for any x, x and
the empty list merge to form
an x, or for any y, the empty
list and y merge to form y.
OK, so there's a piece of
procedure and the logic on
which it's based.
And notice a big difference.
The procedure looked
like this: it
said there was a box--
and all the things we've been
doing have the characteristic
we have boxes and things going
in and things going out--
there was this box called merge,
and in came an x and y,
and out came an answer.
That's the character of the
procedure that we wrote.
These rules don't
look like that.
These rules talk about
a relation.
There's some sort of relation
that in those slides I called
mrege-to-form.
So I said x and y merge
to form z, and
somehow this is a function.
Right?
The answer is a function of x
and y, and here what I have is
a relation between
three things.
And I'm not going to specify
which is the input and which
is the output.
And the reason I want to say
that is because in principle,
we could use exactly those same
logic rules to answer a
lot of different questions.
So we can say, for instance--
imagine giving our machine
those rules of logic.
Not the program, the underlying
rules of logic.
Then it ought to be
able to say--
we could ask it--
1, 3, 7 and 2, 4, 8 merge
to form what?
And that's a question it ought
to be able to answer.
That's exactly the same
question that our list
procedure answered.
But the exact same rules should
also be able to answer
a question like this: 1, 3, 7
and what merged to form 1, 2,
3, 4, 7, 8?
The same rules of logic can
answer this, although the
procedure we wrote can't
answer that question.
Or we might be able to
say what and what
else merge to form--
what and what else merge to
form 1, 2, 3, 4, 7, 8?
And the thing should be able
to go through, if it really
can apply that logic, and deduce
all, whatever is, 2 to
the sixth answers to
that question.
It could be 1 and the rest, or
it could be 1, 2 and the rest.
Or it could be 1 and 3 and 7 and
the rest. There's a whole
bunch of answers.
And in principle, the
logic should be
enough to deduce that.
So there are going to be two big
differences in the kind of
program we're going to look
at and not only list, but
essentially all the programming
you've probably
done so far in pretty much any
language you can think of.
The first is, we're not going
to be computing functions.
We're not going to be talking
about things that take input
and output.
We're going to be talking
about relations.
And that means in principle,
these relations don't have
directionality.
So the knowledge that you
specify to answer this
question, that same knowledge
should also allow you to
answer these other questions
and conversely.
And the second issue is that
since we're talking about
relations, these
relations don't
necessarily have one answer.
So that third question down
there doesn't have a
particular answer, it has a
whole bunch of answers.
Well, that's where
we're going.
This style of programming, by
the way, is called logic
programming, for kind
of obvious reasons.
And people who do logic
programming say that-- they
have this little phrase-- they
say the point of logic
programming is that you use
logic to express what is true,
you use logic to check whether
something is true, and you use
logic to find out
what is true.
The best known logic programming
language, as you
probably know, is
called Prolog.
The language that we're going
to implement this morning is
something we call the query
language, and it essentially
has the essence of prologue.
It can do about the same stuff,
although it's a lot
slower because we're going to
implement it in LISP rather
than building a particular
compiler.
We're going to interpret it on
top of the LISP interpreter.
But other than that,
it can do about the
same stuff as prolog.
It has about the same power
and about the same
limitations.
All right, let's break
for question.
STUDENT: Yes, could you please
repeat what the three things
you use logic programming
to find?
In other words, to find what is
true, learn what is true--
what is the?
PROFESSOR: Right.
Sort of a logic programmer's
little catechism.
You use logic to express what
is true, like these rules.
You use logic to check whether
something is true, and that's
the kind of question I
didn't answer here.
I might say--
another question I could put
down here is to say, is it
true that 1, 3, 7 and 2, 4, 8
merge to form 1, 2, 6, 10 And
that same logic should
be enough to say no.
So I use logic to check what is
true, and then you also use
logic to find out what's true.
All right.
Let's break.
[MUSIC PLAYING BY J.S. BACH]
[MUSIC ENDS]
PROFESSOR: OK, let's go ahead
and take a look at this query
language and operation.
The first thing you might
notice, when I put up that
little biblical database, is
that it's nice to be able to
ask this language questions
in relation to some
collection of facts.
So let's start off and make a
little collection of facts.
This is a tiny fragment of
personnel records for a Boston
high tech company, and here's
a piece of the personnel
records of Ben Bitdiddle.
And Ben Bitdiddle is the
computer wizard in this
company, he's the underpaid
computer
wizard in this company.
His supervisor is all
Oliver Warbucks,
and here's his address.
So the format is we're giving
this information: job, salary,
supervisor, address.
And there are some other
conventions.
Computer here means that Ben
works in the computer
division, and his
position in the
computer division is wizard.
Here's somebody else.
Alyssa, Alyssa P. Hacker is a
computer programmer, and she
works for Ben, and she
lives in Cambridge.
And there's another programmer
who works for Ben
who's Lem E. Tweakit.
And there's a programmer
trainee, who is Louis
Reasoner, and he works
for Alyssa.
And the big wheel of the company
doesn't work for
anybody, right?
That's Oliver Warbucks.
Anyway, what we're going to do
is ask questions about that
little world.
And that'll be a sample
world that we're
going to do logic in.
Let me just write up here, for
probably the last time, what I
said is the very most important
thing you should get
out of this course, and that
is, when somebody tells you
about a language,
you say, fine--
what are the primitives, what
are the means of combination,
how do you put the primitives
together, and then how do you
abstract them, how do you
abstract the compound pieces
so you can use them as pieces
to make something more
complicated?
And we've said this a whole
bunch of times already, but
it's worth saying again.
Let's start.
The primitives.
Well, there's really only one
primitive, and the primitive
in this language is
called a query.
A primitive query.
Let's look at some primitive
queries.
Job x.
Who is a computer programmer?
Or find every fact in the
database that matches job of
the x is computer programmer.
And you see a little
syntax here.
Things without question marks
are meant to be literal,
question mark x means that's a
variable, and this thing will
match, for example, the fact
that Alyssa P. Hacker is a
computer programmer, or
x is Alyssa P. Hacker.
Or more generally, I could
have something with two
variables in it.
I could say, the job of x is
computer something, and
that'll match computer wizard.
So there's something here: type
will match wizard, or
type will match programmer,
or x might match
various certain things.
So there are, in our little
example, only three facts in
that database that
match that query.
Let's see, just to show you some
syntax, the same query,
this query doesn't match the job
of x, doesn't match Lewis
Reasoner, the reason for that
is when I write something
here, what I mean is that this
is going to be a list of two
symbols, of which the first is
the word computer, and the
second can be anything.
And Lewis's job description here
has three symbols, so it
doesn't match.
And just to show you a little
bit of syntax, the more
general thing I might want to
type is a thing with a dot
here, and this is just standard
this notation for
saying, this is a list, of which
the first element is the
word computers, and THE
REST, is something
that I'll call type.
So this one would match.
Lewis's job is computer
programmer trainee, and type
here would be the cdr of this
list. It would be the list
programmer trainee.
And that kind of dot
processing is done
automatically by the
LISP reader.
Well, let's actually try this.
The idea is I'm going to type
in queries in this language,
and answers will come out.
Let's look at this.
I can go up and say, who works
in the computer division?
Job of x is computer dot y.
Doesn't matter what I call
the dummy variables.
It says the answers to that, and
it's found four answers.
Or I can go off and say, tell
me about everybody's
supervisor.
So I'll put in the query,
the primitive query, the
supervisor of x is y.
There are all the supervisor
relationships I know.
Or I could go type in, who
lives in Cambridge?
So I can say, the address of x
is Cambridge dot anything.
And only one person lives
in Cambridge.
OK, so those are primitive
queries.
And you see what happens to
basic interaction with the
system is you type in a query,
and it types out
all possible answers.
Or another way to say that: it
finds out all the possible
values of those variables x and
y or t or whatever I've
called them, and it types out
all ways of taking that query
and instantiating it--
remember that from the rule
system lecture-- instantiates
the query with all possible
values for those variables and
then types out all of them.
And there are a lot
of ways you can
arrange a logic language.
Prolog, for instance, does
something slightly different.
Rather than typing back your
query, prolog would type out,
x equals this and y equals that,
or x sequels this and y
equals that.
And that's a very surface level
thing, you can decide
what you like.
OK.
All right.
So the primitives in
this language?
Only one, right?
Primitive query.
OK.
Means of combination.
Let's look at some compound
queries in this language.
Here's one.
This one says, tell me all the
people who work in the
computer division.
Tell me all the people who work
in the computer division
together with their
supervisors.
The way I write that is
the query is and.
And the job of the x is computer
something or other.
And job of x is computer
dot y.
And the supervisor of x is z.
Tell me all the people in
the computer division--
that's this-- together with
their supervisors.
And notice in this query I
have three variables--
x, y, and z.
And this x is supposed to
be the same as that x.
So x works in the computer
division, and the
supervisor of x is z.
Let's try another one.
So one means of combination
is and.
Who are all the people who
make more than $30,000?
And the salary of some person
p is some amount a.
And when I go and look at a,
a is greater than $30,000.
And LISP value here is a little
piece of interface that
interfaces the query language
to the underlying LISP.
And what the LISP value allows
you to do is call any LISP
predicate inside a query.
So here I'm using the LISP
predicate greater than, so I
say LISP value.
This I say and.
So all the people whose salary
is greater than $30,000.
Or here's a more complicated
one.
Tell me all the people who work
in the computer division
who do not have a supervisor
who works in
the computer division.
and x works in the computer
division.
The job of x is computer
dot y.
And it's not the case that both
x has a supervisor z and
the job of z is computer
something or other.
All right, so again, this x has
got to be that x, and this
z is going to be that z.
And then you see another means
a combination, not.
All right, well, let's
look at that.
It works the same way.
I can go up to the machine and
say and the job of the x is
computer dot y.
And the supervisor of x is z.
And I typed that in
like a query.
And what it types back, what
you see are the queries I
typed in instantiated by
all possible answers.
And then you see there
are a lot of answers.
All right.
So the means of combination
in this language--
and this is why it's called
a logic language--
are logical operations.
Means of combinations are things
like AND and NOT and
there's one I didn't show
you, which is OR.
And then I showed you LISP
value, which is not logic, of
course, but is a little special
hack to interface that
to LISP so you can
get more power.
Those are the means
of combination.
OK, the means of abstraction.
What we'd like to do--
let's go back for second and
look at that last slide.
We might like to take very
complicated thing, the idea
that someone works in a division
but does not have a
supervisor in the division.
And as before, name that.
Well, if someone works in a
division and does not have a
supervisor who works in that
division, that means that
person is a big shot.
So let's make a rule that
somebody x is a big shot in
some department if x works in
the department and it's not
the case that x has a supervisor
who works in the
department.
So this is our means
of abstraction.
This is a rule.
And a rule has three parts.
The thing that says
it's a rule.
And then there's the conclusion
of the rule.
And then there's the
body of the rule.
And you can read this as a piece
of logic which says, if
you know that the body of the
rule is true, then you can
conclude that the conclusion
is true.
Or in order to deduce that
x is a big shot in some
department, it's enough
to verify that.
So that's what rules
look like.
Let's go back and look at that
merge example that I did
before the break.
Let's look at how that would
look in terms of rules.
I'm going to take the logic I
put up and just change it into
a bunch of rules
in this format.
We have a rule.
Remember, there was this
thing merge-to-form.
There is a rule that says,
the empty list and y
merge to form y.
This is the rule conclusion.
And notice this particular
rule has no body.
And in this language, a rule
with no body is something that
is always true.
You can always assume
that's true.
And there was another piece of
logic that said anything in
the empty list merged to
form the anything.
That's this.
A rule y and the empty
list merge to form y.
Those corresponded to the two
end cases in our merge
procedure, but now we're talking
about logic, not about
procedures.
Then we had another rule, which
said if you know how
shorter things merge, you
can put them together.
So this says, if you have a list
x and y and z, and if you
want to deduce that a dot x--
this means constant a onto x,
or a list whose first thing
is a and whose rest is x--
so if you want to deduce that
a dot x and b dot y merge to
form b dot c--
that would say you merge these
two lists a x and b y and
you're going to get something
that starts with b--
you can deduce that if you know
that it's the case both
that a dot x and y merge to form
z and a is larger than b.
So when I merge them, b will
come first in the list. That's
a little translation of the
logic rule that I wrote in
pseudo-English before.
And then just for completeness,
here's the other case.
a dot x and b dot y merge to
form a dot z if x and b dot y
merged to form z and
b is larger than a.
So that's a little program that
I've typed in in this
language, and now let's
look at it run.
So I typed in the merge rules
before, and I could use this
like a procedure.
I could say merge to form
1 and 3 and 2 and 7.
So here I'm using it like
the LISP procedure.
Now it's going to think about
that for a while and apply
these rules.
So it found an answer.
Now it's going to see if there
are any other answers but it
doesn't know a priori there's
only one answer.
So it's sitting here checking
all possibilities, and it
says, no more.
Done.
So there I've used those
rules like a procedure.
Or remember the whole point is
that I can ask different kinds
of questions.
I could say merge to form, let's
see, how about 2 and a.
Some list of two elements which
I know starts with 2,
and the other thing I don't
know, and x and some other
list merge to form
a 1, 2, 3 and 4.
So now it's going to
think about that.
It's got to find--
so it found one possibility.
It said a could be 3, and x
could be the list 1, 4.
And now, again, it's got to
check because it doesn't a
priori know that there
aren't any other
possibilities going on.
Or like I said, I could say
something like merge to form,
like, what and what else merge
to form 1, 2, 3, 4, 5?
Now it's going to think
about that.
And there are a lot of answers
that it might get.
And what you see is here you're
really paying the price
of slowness.
And kind of for three reasons.
One is that this language
is doubly interpreted.
Whereas in a real
implementation, you would go
compile this down to primitive
operations.
The other reason is that this
particular algorithm for
merges is doubly recursive.
So it's going to take
a very long time.
And eventually, this is going
to go through and find--
find what?
Two to the fifth possible
answers.
And you see they come out in
some fairly arbitrary order,
depending on which order
it's going to be
trying these rules.
In fact, what we're going
to do when they edit the
videotape is speed
all this up.
Don't you like taking
out these weights?
And don't you wish you could
do that in your demos?
Anyway, it's still
grinding there.
Anyway, there are 32
possibilities--
we won't wait for it to
print out all of them.
OK, so the needs of abstraction
in this
language are rules.
So we take some bunch of things
that are put together
with logic and we name them.
And you can think of
that as naming a
particular pattern of logic.
Or you can think of that as
saying, if you want to deduce
some conclusion, you can apply
those rules of logic.
And those are three elements
of this language.
Let's break now, and then we'll
talk about how it's
actually implemented.
STUDENT: Does using LISP value
primitive or whatever
interfere with your means to go
both directions on a query?
PROFESSOR: OK, that's a--
the question is, does using LISP
value interfere with the
ability to go both directions
on the query?
We haven't really talked about
the implementation yet, but
the answer is, yes, it can.
In general, as we'll
see at the end--
although I really won't
to go into details--
it's fairly complicated,
especially when you use either
not or LISP value--
or actually, if you use anything
besides only and, it
becomes very complicated
to say when
these things will work.
They won't work quite
in all situations.
I'll talk about that at the end
of the second half today.
But the answer to your question
is, yes, by dragging
in a lot more power from LISP
value, you lose some of the
principal power of logic
programming.
That's a trade-off that
you have to make.
OK, let's take a break.